hey 42 here the first cookbook was
written by the Greeks in 400 BC welcome
to RIF in Quebec there is an old law
that states
marjorine must be a different color than
butter chewing gum while peeling onions
will prevent you from crying there are
eight different time zones in North
America in 1933 the animated fictional
cartoon character Mickey Mouse received
800,000 fan letters every 45 seconds a
house catches fire in the United States
most burglaries happen above the first
but below the seventh floor in a hotel
if you eat an excessive amount of
carrots your skin will turn an orangey
yellow color the coldest object in our
solar system is not Pluto it's Triton
one of Neptune's moons the oldest known
goldfish was 41 years old in ancient
Egypt priests plucked every hair from
their bodies including their eyebrows
and eyelashes to avoid sinking in
quicksand raise your legs slowly and lie
on your back this will distribute your
weight evenly and stop you from sinking
the people of Israel consume more
turkeys per capita than any other
country flies jump backwards before they
take off roses are red
but violets aren't bloom they're violet
the clues in the dumb name thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42